the president's comments on North Korea
come less than 10 days before the Winter
Olympics begin in South Korea the North
will play a significant part in those
games Ben Tracy is in Beijing monitoring
the situation in North Korea Ben good
morning good morning so there's not been
any official reaction from North Korea
just yet but as you mentioned this could
really complicate the fragile
relationship between North and South
Korea that has emerged over these
Olympic Games now keep in mind the North
Korean delegation is expected to arrive
in South Korea tomorrow on Thursday and
the South Korean government has been
trying to do everything it can to ensure
that nothing derails the North's
participation or provokes Kim Jong moon
to launch a missile or do something that
might disrupt the games now Kim
jong-un's regime will likely not take
kindly to the president highlighting a
North Korean defector in his speech or
North Korea's well-documented human
rights abuses the president's speech
could also be seen by the north as
evidence that the u.s. is laying the
groundwork for some sort of military
strike now North Korea is planning its
own show of force next week they're
planning on holding a massive military
parade the day before the Olympics begin
they say this is to mark the 70th
anniversary of the founding of its
military now North Korea rarely holds
its tongue when it is criticized by the
United States especially by President
Trump so you can likely expect in the
next 24 to 48 hours we will hear
something back from North Korea
alright Ben Tracy in Beijing thank you